well it looks like we're actually going
to be doing the last night in soho
trailer reaction today easily the most
requested trailer to cover this week and
i've told some people
why we haven't done it we have some
reactor friends and i already knew this
was going to happen to them that were
you're getting the copyright
claims and partial blocks which really
affect
videos a lot and universal and focused
features always claims
or partially blocks our videos and it's
a pain in the butt talks
but we're here today because gotta say
thank you to rich wallet for sponsoring
this video
so glad ridge is sponsoring this video
because edgar wright is like a father to
me you know your actual father watches
these videos and he wishes he was edgar
wright
and i think the rich products are a
great father's day gift these
transitions are so
smooth greg tell them about the bridge
john
and now i'm gonna tell them a true story
about radio it's an actual true story
guys ridge makes these awesome metal
plated wallets they come in titanium
aluminum
carbon fiber they have thirty thousand
five star reviews they're sleek
they're minimal in design and they're
rfid blocking to keep all your
information
safe you can get free shipping and
returns world why they got a new
woven kevlar iphone case look at that
thing and you could use
promo code reject nation to save
yourself 10 on your order just visit
ridge.com
reject nation but what i wanted to tell
you is a true story the last time i went
to colorado i was on a plane
and next to me was a man named abraham
and what
struck up a conversation with us i
pulled out my
wallet and then he looked at my wallet
and
said that is a really great wallet
what wallet is that and i said it's a
rich wallet
and then literally the whole flight we
talked with each other
the entire time follow each other on
instagram
he even recommended these headphones to
me which are not rich so i'm not going
to mention what brand they are ridge
not only is a great father's day gift
it's also a great way to make
friends let's watch this trailer finally
wow this is the best trailer ever
[Music]
feels like a nicholas wooden refin movie
oh yeah
or an a24 film
whoa what the hell what the
hell
it's like watching the neon demon yeah
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh she's an odd buzz
oh that was like the first promo image
they released one
wow
[Laughter]
get your 1960s freeze frame in there
yeah
all right you you sons of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was a great [ __ ] trick
i see what is like everyone who's best
achievement for the books
yeah yeah that was pretty cinema i gotta
say i don't know
much about this movie [ __ ] right when
he was really becoming
popular as a director writer a lot of
his stuff had a bit of
self-awareness spoof quality to it and
then when he did baby driver
that was when it was like no i'm really
committing to a genre
and i'm not doing like a spoof at all
it's it's an
actual getaway heist driver action film
here for a guy who
really became known to the world through
films like shawn of the dead a horror
comedy
it's cool to see him really do a full-on
psychological
horror film one that is
not at all looking like it's funny
that it's just truly unnerving
i like i was saying first in the
beginning i was like oh this kind of
reminds me like the movie eighth grade
that's social anxiety of a young girl as
it kept going it started feeling like
those obviously freaking
annapurna a24 trailers a little bit of
nicholas wind and reffin you can always
count on beautiful
composition and cinematography when it
comes to edgar wright i love
kind of the uh throwback to like old
school like kind of feels like old
school i don't wanna say hollywood more
like
theater yeah yeah they look like they're
in new york right yeah
you know they're they're yeah i mean
there's a place like that that has a lot
of extravagant ballrooms and places
where high society hangs out and there
are people dancing
and whatnot yeah a little bit of darren
aronofsky too black swanish vibes trying
to get it all out of the way before
john dominates the brilliant commentary
he's about to give
so please john take it away no i mean
this is an interesting trailer to me
partly because now we're at the phase of
edgar wright's
career filmography where it's sort of
you know we're looking at a
new phase i feel like because yeah baby
driver was sort of stepping
a bit beyond the things we know him for
but with a lot of the flavors that we
know him for and the things
that struck me about this trailer was
just that a it's much more
at least it's leading with a deliberate
visual pace and tone
like i associate i can write with a lot
of punch and a lot of like really
clockwork editing and stuff like that
and this looks like it's pulled back in
that department not that you know like
at the end when the horror is ramping up
it doesn't
get kind of loud and and you know almost
insidious like at points when like the
walls are breaking or whatever
like i feel like this is a movie that
could be a slow build and then go
bonkers right at the very end like a lot
of 60s movies do and this clearly has
some love for that era i like the
mystery this trailer portrays because i
can't quite
glean the nature of the time aspect you
know
not that it's i don't know it seems like
time travel would be a
too simplistic reductive way of
describing it you know
but it seems like it has some kind of
sci-fi twist about it
as well as the horror that looks pretty
sweet and also you know a lot of shots
that are clearly
like the eyes in the reflection and the
knife
and that freeze frame at the end like a
lot of like italian horror yeah
yeah horror visual tropes and stuff like
that and and i
like it like we sound more like we know
we're talking about when we talk about
horror films than we do superhero movies
this is my favorite genre after all uh
but yeah
and and that's the thing is i feel like
too it's easy
in a lot of movies and i'm sure that
there are specific
film homage references that a lot of
cinephiles could probably pick out of
this but it doesn't feel
as lurid as some movies do like i don't
feel like he's going full on tarantino
with the sort of like here's
this movie i'm homaging and here's this
movie oh he's a song he's a damn good
storyteller that's the thing he cares
about that first and foremost and i feel
like a good
style homage payer without just being
like check out the scene
you all know the scene that i'm homage
and we just got to matt smith on doctor
who on patreon like for six episodes and
loving him as its whole like to move his
trailer came at the right time for us
perfect and i just saw a couple of anya
taylor joy's
snl sketches haven't seen the queen's
gambit but
you know those sketches are what got me
interested in here
my favorite performances okay so the
description of this edgar read
psychological thriller about a young
girl passionate in fashion design who is
mysteriously able to enter the 1960s
where she encounters her idol
a dazzling wannabe singer but 1960s
oh it's in london okay i thought it was
so hot yeah okay because there's also a
soho in new york so that means
is there a soho in new york that's where
my mind went yeah and there's a soho in
london it gets confusing
okay so 1960s london is not what it
appears
and time seems to fall apart with shady
consequences
it's cool you know like i feel like he's
kind of had you know how like jordan
peele
demonstrated his horror knowledge and
nuances with sketches within key and
peel
like horror comedy and that's kind of
what edgar wright did and then
now he does like horror movies
and this is like where i feel like he's
gone with this yeah
we know him to kind of bring like the
fun and horror and well i'm sure there
might be a little bit of a fun
punch to it all this looks like a very
dreadful experience but with a a
pacing rhythm and popping neon colors
that are gonna
exhilarate the pulse yeah
all right you guys were right it's
partially blocked on your mobile or in
some parts of the world i'm sorry you
can't view this don't yell at me
yell at universal or focus features and
yell at the reps who send us these
trailers
just don't help us clear them guys
help us help you help us you have no
idea how many times i've submitted to
streets being
like guys i don't even care if it's
claimed just can you get it unblocked
so many times i've said that to these
makes no sense anyway
thanks so much for being here thank you
to ridge for sponsoring this video
and hey we'll catch you guys soon